the precise details of their origins are
lost to us but it is said the Valerians
were once a modest community of
Shepherds tending their flocks on a
small Peninsula of the Great Eastern
continent one fateful day in a volcanic
area known as the 14 fires they made a
shattering discovery dragons
hey everybody its charlie really awesome
game of thrones related news season 8
the prequel series in a possible second
prequel series so we got to break all
this down if you're finding me for the
first time there's a new round of that
4k blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video YouTube changed a
couple features so there's new details
about how the giveaways work at the end
of this video you said to make a couple
of minor changes in the way that I
communicate with you guys so biggest
thing first
the long night prequel series that was
confirmed might be shooting as soon as
October if it went well that HBO would
move forward on shooting the rest of the
episodes just because the pilot has been
greenlit doesn't mean that they picked
the show up to series remember normal
series on HBO about 10 episodes they
said that they're spending about the
same amount of money for the same scale
and the same grandeur as the main show
is right now so they want to make sure
that everything looks amazing before
they give away a hundred million dollars
to the people that are producing all
these different series if you've been
following the series for a long time
especially production you're probably
not surprised to hear that they'll be
filming in a lot of the same locations
that they film the main series it's
gonna take place in Westeros just a
couple thousand years before the events
on the main show so the terrain will
look a little bit different but not that
different I don't know if we're gonna
actually see the cracking of Westeros
during the war with the first men
because that precedes the long night by
quite a bit we might hear legends of the
cracking of the arm of door and they're
just a lot of big geological events
caused by the children of the forest in
their pursuit of getting rid of the
first men before they sign their pact
there was actually a second time that
they tried to crack Westeros in half
with the hammer of waters on the Isle of
faces but it didn't work like they were
actually trying to keep the first men
out of the north so their last-ditch
attempt which failed was to crack
Westeros in half again maybe if they
decide to do flashbacks on the prequel
series then we'll see a version of that
remember the story about why they waited
a couple extra months to start filming
season seven which contributed to the
extra delay which also led to further
delays on season 8 getting out because
it needs to wait for winter to come to
places where they were filming scenes
where it would traditionally be summer
same climate with the long night prequel
series because they're heading into the
neverending winter on that series
separately there was a report from the
iron bank aka AT&T which just brought
Time Warner and said the HBO needed to
start earning more money by becoming
more broadly popular around the world so
imagine in this equation the AT&T just
bought Time Warner Time Warner owns HBO
so AT&T is like the new iron bank their
version of Thai CONUS Taurus claimed
that HBO was not earning enough money so
HBO is terrified of a time without Game
of Thrones because Game of Thrones just
to give you an idea of how much more
popular it is is maybe like 10 times
more popular than any other series HBO
has done the last couple of years the
majority of the new subscribers the Game
of Thrones brings in only subscribe for
Game of Thrones meaning when the shows
not on they bail HBO misses out on
hundreds and millions of dollars in
subscription money AT&T does not like
that henceforth that's why they're
pushing to get this prequel series out
the year after season 8 airs so
tentatively pencil in April May 2020 for
the premiere date for that first prequel
series now that assumes that everything
goes well with this first pilot then you
have the three other pilots that they're
working on there's a rumor now that
because of this AT&T issue like them
telling HBO you need to start earning
way more money that HBO is feeling
pressured to release to Game of Thrones
prequel series concurrently meaning you
would get 20 weeks of Game of Thrones to
feed your addiction instead of the
normal ten because normal season HBO has
about ten episodes this morning some
news outlets were reporting that the
other second game of Thrones prequel
that they were developing wait for it
this old sound familiar was called
Empire of ash what does that remind you
of ancient Valyria so for those of you
that were really hoping that they would
do in ancient Valyria series it sounds
like that's definitely one of the other
pilots but they haven't greenlit any of
the other ones yet so remember the one
that's gonna be filming in October they
were talking about that a while ago
there's been no talk of any of the
others moving forward yet but if the
name is starting to leak out on this
other one it sounds like it's their
second best option so if they actually
move forward on this they film the pilot
early next year then you know similar
production schedule eight to ten months
to get the entire season out it probably
wouldn't be ready to go until 22
so like imagine season 8 airs in 2019
the year after that we get the long
night prequel series begins we get like
seven seasons of that they also might be
pressured to release that second series
concurrently so in a couple years we
might actually have 20 weeks of Game of
Thrones there's actually a description
that was released for this Valyrian
series so I don't know how authentic
this is so take it with a grain of salt
but it says it will explore the social
economic and political crisis which tore
apart the Valyrian Empire from within
much like on Game of Thrones political
factions will battle for supremacy while
a larger existential threat looms on the
horizon so think of the White Walkers
the knight King that big threat that's
been forming the last several seasons on
Game of Thrones main series as being the
doom on this Valyrian series like it
will all be sliding downhill I think it
was a couple years ago I actually did a
couple videos on the causes of the doom
of Valyria there are natural geological
reasons for why it happened but there's
also this magical connotation because
magic exists in Game of Thrones you have
to imagine that that series would feel a
little bit more like HBO's Rome this
grand Empire that was in a state of
decline headed for this giant
catastrophe but at the same time because
it's ancient Valyria they're dragons
everywhere covering the sky they're
references to a Knauer Targaryen and his
daughter Danis the dreamer the one that
actually dreamt about the doom the cause
for the Targaryens leaving for
Dragonstone and surviving the actual
doom itself so right now it seems like
those are our two best options for the
prequel series the long night which
seems like it will premiere in 2020 and
then this ancient Valyria series which
could premiere a little while after that
but I would be blown away if both of
these end up airing at the same time
what I think is more likely is is that
this long night TV series is strong
enough they'll just air that for say
like five seasons then overlap a little
bit with another series so even though
they're talking about doing a prequel
series right now they'll do more series
after this next prequel series is over
that's assuming that it's successful and
it runs for another five to seven
seasons - so you have to imagine that
there'll be like 14 or 15 more years of
Game of Thrones minimum there's a whole
lot of stuff to unpack in all this news
HBO hasn't officially confirmed this
ancient Valyria series so I'll do a new
video when they do but leave
all your requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Joe Weaver please email me on the
back end of my channel you can find the
contact information there YouTube just
up and got rid of that messaging tool so
if you need to contact me about giveaway
stuff you do it using that email so
while you wait for everything click here
for that Arya Stark teaser and click
here to listen to Jaime Lannister talk
about season 8 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight